renaissance artist and all-around smart
cookie
leonardo da vinci famously painted the
mona lisa and the last supper
but he also may have been the first
person to design one of these
nope not the wakeboard that thing in the
sky
also known as a helicopter
[Music]
and it's not only wake boarders the
helicopter pilots are helping out
[Music]
the best can use their skills to save
calves from frozen lakes
da vinci was ahead of his time although
there was less cow rescues in his
pictures
from memory but before a pilot can head
off for a little cow skimming
they need to know their heli science
a helicopter generates lift from its
rotating blades
adjusting the collective pitch changes
the angle of all blades simultaneously
allowing the helicopter to increase or
decrease in altitude
adjusting the cyclic pitch will change
the angle of each blade at specific
parts of its rotation
creating more lift on one side leading
to forwards
backwards and side to side motion
changing the pitch of the tail rotor
blades rotates the helicopter left
or right like a rudder
thus you need to master a combination of
cyclic pitch
collective pitch and tail rotor pitch
for successful flight
okay let's take it one step at a time
first we need to take off which is
easier said than done in a homemade car
copter
well this doesn't look dangerous
please fasten your seat belts as we may
be experiencing some turbulence
and a touch of impact force
the faster he's pulled the quicker the
blades auto rotate
which eventually creates enough lift to
race him
but as the car copter rotates to the
side that lift force makes it travel
sideways
faster than his rudder can correct
luckily the pilot was fine which is more
than can be said for the reliant robin
maybe best stick to a proper helicopter
with an actual tail rotor
[Music]
this research pilot is using a
combination of collective pitch to
descend
and cyclic pitch to move forwards now
for the perfect landing
ah that wasn't important was it
a sudden dip in collective pitch causes
blades to intersect with the power line
so it's shorted
but i don't think anyone noticed yeah
that might be a bit of a giveaway
yes like take off coming in for a
landing can be the trickiest skill
nailed that one though
the pilot adjusts the cyclic pitch to
create more lift on the right-hand side
drifting the helicopter to the left but
the building has possibly affected the
airflow and his aerodynamics
so the pilot decides to teach it a
lesson
i mean i could see it coming but then
again i am
cyclic
[Music]
you